[Music]
yeah El Turk welcome to H startup Nation
United thank you for joining me from a
pretty far away H yet um making a
significant impact with um an
identification of a gap and an
opportunity in the current standing of
of the war I really appreciate your time
I know how bus you are thank you very
much for joining me thank you thank you
Michael and thank you for reaching out
to me so I will be able to expose a
little bit more what we are doing and
hopefully more people will support
us 100% 100% okay so y before we dive
into um the war and like for Israel and
what we're doing here tell me a little
bit about yourself H tell me a little
bit about what you're doing the day
today where you're from what you do for
sure H by my accent you can hear that I
was born and raised in Israel about 10
years ago we moved to the States almost
10 years in New York at some point in
the in the corona we started thinking
okay what's next because obviously the
weather in the Northeast is not amazing
for us and we found ourselves in Puerto
Rico so not many
Israelis are here so we are actually
encouraging people to move here um and
in terms of the professional path that I
went through since my military service
about 20 years ago I'm I've been in in
Tech and been fortunate enough to be in
some some startups that grew very nicely
um my my focus is around the postel area
where you need to get customers to
succeed make sure that customers are
satisfied and make sure that the product
that you're trying to penetrate into the
market is actually working well for
customers so all for to make sure that
products are being successful in those
markets um about three years ago I've
decided to not to jump to to another H
roller coaster to another startup and to
start my own business H so today fast
forward I'm working with the small and
large startups also some Public public
companies that do need to do the the
next phase of of customer success I'll
call it customer success 2.0 and make
sure that they are implementing the
right methodologies and playbooks and
the recruiting the right people for for
the right tasks um and yeah I think
that's beautiful I love it October
7eventh hits you're not in Israel yet
you are experiencing it from far away
tell me a little bit about what that
what where were you when it hit what was
the sequence of events from the moment
it started 6:30 a.m on on that Saturday
Israel time and where were you and and
what happened there what what was your
shift like yeah yeah so woke up at
around 7 a.m. eastern time I got so many
messages so I didn't realize what's
going on and some painful messages that
okay what is going on and it took couple
of hours to really understand the the
volume or the what what did it mean for
Israel um I think three or four hours
after we immediately opened the fund to
raise money so it was like a few very
good friends of of mine and Roy my
spouse house that we came together we
opened a fund that's the first thing
that we did and within five or six days
we already raised about 80
80k 880,000 which was a which by the way
we we should already decide where to to
lead that money for um and secondly we
started seeing okay what kind of
initiatives other people doing whether
in Israel or outside of Israel to help
the affected families and whoever is is
needing our help we started getting
involved in sending equipment either to
um to Citizens or to uh to the military
in terms of what is missing H so we we
started doing it quite immediately and
it's amazing to see the the support of
so many people wanting to get involved
and and donate and and really help out
with with that type of operation and the
few days after all of that happened we
realized that we need to H we need to
raise the voice of those who are
supporting Israel there is so many bad
Happ how did you get to that realization
what was sort of the the process that
you've observed and the the the arena
that we're playing in that led you to
understand
that we could see so many mixed messages
and so many people feeling as if like
you know Israel is left by itself no one
is supporting it I could I could talk to
people whether it's family or friends or
colleagues or whether seeing those posts
on one of the social medias so I realize
that we do need to expose the ones that
do support Israel and there are many
there are many that's the that that's
the optimistic part of of the story okay
so there are
many like that but but yeah yeah so
there are many non Israelis non-jewish
that do support Israel and they are
raising their voice although they're
getting a lot of messages on their post
of you know you're you're not on the
right side or you know God God will not
be with you or you know shaming them and
so on but the idea is that we the
Israelis the Jewish and the people who
do do believe that
terrorism is not right do need to
support those
influencers yeah 100% okay and so what
what is the sort of the operation behind
this idea what what what is it actually
look like this this support yeah so what
we've came up with is a very simple idea
what we will do is we will H gather on a
daily basis a posts of those influencers
and when I'm talking about influencers
it could be Israeli like galgadot who
has about 110 million followers in
different social medias or people like
LeBron James or Brook Shields or so many
other ER people who believe that Israel
has the right to defend itself um and we
are basically showing that to the user
who is going to the website it's like
for israel.com very simple and every day
they are seeing those posts they can
actually go into each one of those posts
and support whether liking or adding a
message or saving or sharing and then in
order also to get our audience feel good
about themselves we are we are counting
how many they are supporting the idea is
to also show you how much support you
are giving to Israel so a little bit of
gamification and why is this important
in the global in the global scheme of
things let's let's go up a little bit
and and discuss sort of the on on a more
strategic level of why why is this an
impactful project in the context of not
only this this the the war but but in
general about you know what's happening
with
Israel yeah I think that obviously ly
what you know unfortunately what what we
are seeing that although we had that
event happening on October 7th all of a
sudden in the streets of H you know
almost every country in the world there
are people ER for Israel or against
Israel and obviously the um um the
opinion of so many people is also
unclear okay and we have to raise our
voice we have to make sure
that the messaging is getting out there
to as many people as possible so for
example you know my my own a network or
your own network maybe we are connected
to 400 500 people okay the idea is to in
order to get to as many people as
possible we need to find those
influencers that will get much more
exposure okay and not only in a certain
region or a certain country we want to
try and get that the messages around
Israel why they are supporting Israel
will get to as many people in the
globe and and what is the way to to do
that so operationally so you you
identify walk me through just the the
pipeline you identify these these these
um these posts these influences you
amplify them through through the reach
of people that are part of this part of
this community and and and then through
the website how how to how from from a
product perspective how does that work
and how do you get this to actually
scale and impact yeah yeah so first of
all we we just soft launched like a
couple of days ago so is still you know
planning how to make sure that we're
marketing it to H to so many places and
to get as much exposure as possible but
basically we created two two main teams
okay so one team is one that is all for
you know all day long they are in a
social media so they are sourcing a
posts and then we have a team that is
verify verifying the data in the post
because I want to make sure that
whatever I'm exposing to my audience I
want to make sure that it's all for for
Israel okay and by the way post that I I
we've uploaded like a week ago okay we
could see that some of those influencers
unfortunately H changed the wording or
took off the post so we need to also
maintain we also need to maintain those
ER that data um and thirdly we are now
building a network of people that
outside of the US or Israel we're
looking for people who can support us in
that operation in different countries we
have Australia we have Japan we're
working on trying to get people in
Europe to make sure that we are exposing
that those posts not only for a certain
region we we are trying to get to as
many countries as possible phenomenal
that's that's amazing what has this
experience been like for you working on
this during this time
you know how how has it been you know
what are you sensing from the people
around you that are part of this and are
developing this and the group you yeah I
think there is a common theme that for
example if I'm seeing a you know someone
who is in a bad mood or sending a said
message through you know WhatsApp or
text or something and I'm sending them
that link to the website all of a sudden
people are saying I needed that it's
like a very optimistic
boost that they need okay because what
we are doing here we are focusing on the
good and on the part that is supporting
Israel obviously we do not need also
those initiatives that are dealing with
the other side on how to clear those and
and what we can do on on the other side
but at least the niche that we've taken
is that we want to focus on who is
supporting Israel and make them bigger
and bigger and bigger okay H so
definitely the um the feedback that
we've gotten is really good because at
least that gives energy to the people
around us yeah I I I you know as you're
saying saying this I'm thinking about
how you know this is I've been talking
in this show a lot about the United
internally with the Israeli ecosystem
and how you know we we amplify internal
voices a lot and and we feel because we
feel it we do it even without trying we
see it on the street we see in our
internal WhatsApp messages there's
essentially what's happening is this
this I I imagine as a metaphor this
Vortex happening around us where we're
amplifying this energy and we're
amplifying these voices internally and I
think what you're bringing into this
equation you're bringing in a a more
Global understanding and Global sphere
where this United is not is not just
internal but we need to we need to bring
in all we need to expose and amplify and
unite those that want to already be a
part of it you're you're not trying to
convince them to to to to give their
voice into unight you're you're taking
them and you're you're congratulating
them and you're you're you're inviting
them to be a part of this
Vortex and and and it's a and I think
that's what's really really cool and why
I I particularly resonate with with the
work that you're doing and and why why I
think it's so important I think that we
are entering a new world of the in the
Creator economy where citizen journalism
and every influencer has a unique voice
that's profound it's sometimes more
meaningful than the the the quick Hasty
headlines that we see and and and people
that get down to the to the root and
authentically represent how what they
think and and especially you know in in
a true context um giving them that
amplification is I think something very
very important in what we do and and I I
will be happy to support however I can
so I just want to thank you for the
amazing work thank thank you thank you
Michael I will just I will just add one
thing which at least helps me and Roy my
spouse on those difficult days it's like
a shift the anger or the sadness to to
do something even if it's small even if
it's a calling 10 people in Israel and
to to you know tell them a funny story
or a good thing that happened to you at
work today do something do something
with with that uh with that energy
because every every little thing count
really it's h it's amazing how how that
that event actually United all of us and
it it took exactly exactly an hour for
so many people around the world to to
act
so incredible y thank you so much H
continue making a positive impact and
thank you very very much
awesome
[Music]